[Music]
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
look at that look at that
who thinks he's smarter than you why he
think he's smarter than you
this is just
this one
look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser
alex jones is lying to you
that might come as a shock man
[Music]
jones has fake callers this is
[Music]
censorship d banking arrest tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that corporate
takeover censorship d banking arrest
tyranny
look at that
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship debanking
tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser he's a disgrace
and he's a disgrace
and he's with his christ and he's with
his grace
[Music]
[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now costs 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three boxes
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
bring my mango back down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
healthy
and highway robbery is what you're doing
well welcome everybody we're struggling
through some kind of technical issue
something seems to be up with the twitch
element of our stream today it it
stopped and then we had to restart only
twitch and then now
i don't know what's going on something
very strange is happening but we have a
lot to cover and a lot to talk about
today we're joining the johnny depp
trial in progress they're currently
speaking with christian carino the
former agent for johnny depp and amber
heard let's listen i'm going to keep
things getting you know getting
everything ready here and let's see
what's going on because of the metoo
movement allegations
other than mr jackman
not that i work with directly now
in any of your discussions with mr
brookman
did you ask him what mr depp could do
to become employable by disney again or
to be able to get any part of any
pirates this is weird franchise going
forward
no
why not
because
they're
in cases like this there is nothing
anybody can do it is the
directive of the studio to and they have
the sole right to
make the judgment whether they can
continue to employ somebody or not
and your understanding from your
discussions with mr bruckheimer is that
disney had made
the
judgment to decide that they could no
longer employ mr black is that correct
yes but but not
solely based on conversations with mr
brockheimer it was cumulative
with the internal and external
conversations
what did
mr
lord say
that led you to the new god
that disney had made with the decision
the judgment that they did not were not
able to employ mr death
just just that the decision had been
made
what did mr wiggles say
about
business making the judgment of whether
they would not be able to employ mr
death perfect same thing
just like they made the decision
right
you aware of any problems
on the step
with mr depp during the filming of
pirates park
are you aware of mr depp uh engaging
your alcohol and drug use being tardy
any of those issues during the formula
pirate spot
um i'm aware of him being tardy but he's
been tardy on everything in his entire
life
were you aware of whether that was
troublesome to
disney during the filming of pirates 5.
i think it's troublesome to everybody
but
uh everyone
has learned how to produce a film switch
feeds
dealing to deal with it
working wrong yep
yes
do you know whether there was anyone on
the set of pirates 5 who wasn't willing
to deal with it and was quite irritated
no
were you
aware
that
the filming had to be shut down for a
period of time
after mr dev injured his finger
yes
were you aware of any disagreements
between mr depp and disney including mr
bailey and others who were on the
project
about
artistic differences in other words
where mr depp thought something should
be this way or something should be that
way and they didn't agree
yes
okay what is your understanding of that
there was a difference of opinion on
how the film was edited
and what is your understanding of what
mr depp thought it should be
i i don't
know how to describe the difference
between
the disney edit and johnny's preferred
edit
i think
johnny uh
told me about it talked about it a
little bit
do you know how well pirates 5 did at
the box
not exactly
do you know whether it was it was more
successful or less successful than
earlier pirates franchise points i think
it was slightly less than i wasn't the
most successful
installment of that franchise
do you know whether mr depp has a pay or
play
clause
that would
pay him even if he was not in the
subsequent pirate ships
in six
yes
i don't think he does
have
you or any anyone at caa on behalf of mr
death made any efforts with disney
to
find any roles for mr depp
since
he filmed
pirate spy
my efforts were probably primarily
around houdini which at one point was a
film
but
um other people at ca for sure did yes
[Music]
um
i would start with jack wiggum
wow
um we'll now play volume two of mr
carino's deposition at which
okay maybe time for afternoon sure he's
close enough to it absolutely around all
right before we get to volume two let's
go ahead and take a uh 15-minute break
please not talk to anybody about the
case and don't do the outside research
thank you
all right guys i'm gonna get right into
something very special for you i have
ready to go today
an interview hot off the presses with
another one of these trump endorsed
republicans this is john gibbs
now i'm not you know how joe biden says
i'm not supposed to be talking about
this i'm not supposed to be playing this
right now because we have big plans for
this big big plans but
i'm willing to play like the first five
or seven minutes right now okay
if people like it and this is whacked
okay if people like it
after the trial i'd be willing to do the
entire thing
if we get to our hundred members okay so
i'm gonna give you five to seven minutes
no matter what my team's going to go
crazy because they want to debut this
stuff in an explosive way
uh i do want to say thanks to charles
wieland who just grabbed the twitch
prime subscription okay so i'm going to
we're i'm just going to play it we'll
just start and depending on whether
people like it depending on whether
people say this is worthy of a
membership or a twitch prime
subscription
after the trial concludes which is like
two hours from now or something or
through breaks or whatever we will we
will squeeze in elements of it is that
fair okay let's start
conversations with a number of different
republicans running in the 2022 midterm
elections today we're going to be
speaking with john gibbs john gibbs is a
trump endorsed republican the former
assistant secretary for community
planning and development at hud in the
trump administration and is running in
michigan's third congressional district
the incumbent in that race is peter
meyer
it's great to have you on john i really
appreciate your time thanks for having
me on david i really appreciate it so
let's start with something really easy
just to to to kind of get started um
donald trump took a a a bit of issue
with your opponent's last name having a
silent j in it he seemed not to like
that at a recent rally you take no issue
with the spelling of your opponent's
name right
well i think the difference is i'm from
michigan and so we grew up seeing the
supermarket chain and whatnot so we're
really used to it but i can see how
someone who's not from here like
president trump would not be familiar
with that spelling or how i pronounce it
so you know that's just how i look at it
beautiful okay so um
i want to start with
what is leading you to run most people
who choose to run say well to some
degree uh i mean people in media and
people in politics in a sense there's a
narcissistic element right like if
you're in media and you want to talk you
have to on some level think what i'm
saying is at least as interesting as
what anybody else is going to have to
say and if you're going to run for for
office to some degree
you believe you can do a better job than
the person that's there so tell me about
that what problems do you see that you
think you can fix
um well i mean the list goes on and on
but we have inflation uh which is
causing gas prices to you know skyrocket
through the roof we have uh
empty shelves at stores and you have
high prices at grocery stores as well
for basic things like chicken or pork
chops whatever it might be this is
having a huge impact on the middle class
and working working-class folks
especially the poor and minorities you
really got to step up and do something
about this so um and that's just
domestically that doesn't talk about
afghanistan and the botched patrol and
ukraine and what's going on there so i
think there's just a very long list of
issues that we need to address and i
think um very humbly based on my
experience in dc for four years in our
administration i got to learn the
machinery of how government works um i
was there for longer than my this takes
a turn very quickly okay everybody relax
everybody relax primary opponent has
been there so i've got more experience
than him in that
also i'm a regular guy i'm not from uh
you know a super super loaded background
um so i know what it's like to connect
with regular folks so i think i've got
the best of both worlds there but david
i do have a point i mean you have people
who are narcissistic and this profession
does attract those kind of people and i
myself after our administration was not
planning on going into politics i was in
fact planning on becoming a regular
person again uh you know maybe doing
some work for a think tank or something
and just uh you know getting out of the
spotlight for a bit uh but then some
friends you know for uh
said hey why don't you go back home to
michigan and uh you know take a run
against this peter meyer guy who voted
on p trump and uh it took me a while i
thought about it a lot i prayed about it
i made sure i had my ducks in a row and
they ended up diving in a head first to
do it but it's not really necessarily i
was thinking i was kind of looking
forward to being a regular person again
so
yeah i mean it does really take
something to drop in here and do this
it's very busy you know you're gonna get
attacked and there's long hours and uh
there's scrutiny and things but i do
really think it's worth it because um
you know we need the leadership in there
which is lacking right now so you
mentioned three issues there the first
one was was inflation and and price gas
prices and uh product product prices
that's uh that's something that's
happening globally right now there's a
number of issues there as one of 435
members of congress in the united states
what would you do to deal with the issue
of inflation which is a global one
well it's a global issue to some degree
uh but a lot of this money that's been
printed and the spending that's
happening does have global impact
because the investors take that money
and they invest it all around the world
so i do think the europeans certainly
have their share of guilt in this for uh
doing some of the same stuff we're doing
but i think when you look at the kind of
spending and the kind of money printing
that's happening you're getting what's
called the cantillon effect which is
where all this money goes in to the
economy in an efficient way and ends up
driving up prices um in a way that is
harmful to regular folks so
we do have to look at the money printing
uh and the spending uh which are two of
the critical uh points behind this and
david you have a very good point if i
were to win god willing i'm one of 435
so i need to form coalitions i need to
have people that are on my side i need
to have a maturity to understand that
everybody that we're in coalition with
won't agree on every issue but john i
hate to interrupt but i really like that
i love talking about policy and we were
i want to stay on that instead of the
coalition
you're talking about money printing now
joe biden's administration did pass this
infrastructure package and that includes
government spending and we could debate
whether it's the type of spending that
you like or that you don't like but the
deficit declined during joe biden's
first year compared to donald trump's
last year in other words spending in
total the the rate at which we overspent
went down in the first year of joe
biden's presidency would you would you
agree with those numbers from the
congressional budget office which is
nonpartisan not the debt now remember i
know you know the difference you're a
harvard guy
the deficit went down in joe biden's
first year do you agree with those
numbers or you dispute them i'll need to
check that because i've actually heard
differing views on that so i'd want to
go back and look out numbers and see if
there's any fuzzy math going on there um
as a general rule do you dispute numbers
from the congressional budget office or
is that a fair source in your mind
um i think it's not so much uh fair or
not it's a matter of there are many ways
to uh to look at these numbers there are
different ways of calculating deficit in
terms of what you include what don't you
include does it come off the budget this
year or next year after so i think
there's lots of different ways to slice
the pizza here and i need to look at the
way they're doing that to to make a
determination on that would you agree
that at least the congressional budget
office is doing it the same way every
year is that at least fair they are
consistent in how they measure the
deficit
i'd have to take a look at that again
and they'll talk about their methodology
to uh to see what's the case there but
uh so let me ask you this then if you're
not sure whether we can trust the
numbers of the congressional budget
office what numbers do you have as a
basis to say that the spending is out of
control
oh we can easily look at the amount of
money the government's spending that's a
much simpler uh calculation there we can
easily look at inflation uh cpi and
whatnot
those are pretty standard in the way
they're calculated so uh we have a
pretty good sense of what those numbers
but i think so let's see but the the
problem is you blamed the spending on
the inflation so like for example in
this conversation i'm agreeing with you
inflation has been high we're 100 on the
state there's no dispute about those
numbers
you made the assertion that you believe
the inflation to some degree is because
the spending is out of control i said
typically we look at the congressional
budget office for that and they found
that the deficit was down in joe biden's
first year of the presidency you said
you're not sure if you trust those
numbers and when i asked you well how do
you know spending is up you said well
because i looked at the inflation
numbers but your first claim was the
inflation numbers you believe are
because spending was up but now you're
saying the inflation numbers are the
spending numbers that doesn't make sense
does it it doesn't make sense as high
gas prices that regular people cannot
afford well it doesn't make sense is
that black pastures come to me saying
people in our congregation cannot afford
to drive to work because gas prices are
too high what doesn't make sense is that
the price of a pack of chicken or beef
or whatever you're buying at the grocery
store is twice as high that certainly
doesn't make sense and so that's the
problem we got to solve right we agree
gas prices are high but you made the
assertion that it's because of biden
spending whereas gas prices are up
globally and what i'm trying to do is to
is to make that connection but maybe
maybe we're just not not going to be
able to do that let me ask you a
different question do you agree that
since the peak about two months ago
gas prices are now down about 20 percent
do you dispute those numbers
um what i do know is that gas prices are
still far too high one of the reasons
for that is for example shutting down
the keystone xl pipeline and totally
gutting all efforts to have american
energy independence uh so we've got to
go back and reverse those policies so
that we can be producing more of our own
uh supply which will bring prices down
okay but so let's so three different
things there you didn't answer my
question and you also made two claims
that were wrong so i'm gonna tr i'm
gonna do my best to keep keep up here so
do you agree gas prices are down about
20 from their peak two months ago um
what i agree on is that gas prices are
slightly higher than they were uh when
joe biden came into office and we got to
fix this problem and bring it back down
do you dispute that the gas prices are
down 20
um
what i dispute is that uh gas prices are
good they are not good they're still too
high okay that's fair let's so
is 5 10 15 20 whatever one might be is
still too high that's the point fair so
now see john you don't really care if
it's down 20 over the past couple of
months whatever but what i do care about
is way higher than it needs to be so you
made an assertion and i agree see i mean
i can very simply agree with you you're
right they're still too high so you have
see how i'm very simply agreeing with
you
are you disputing just that they've come
down 20 or do or do you agree that they
have
um i try to spend time on the relevant
questions when i look at my policy and
the relevant issue here is we got to
bring the gas prices down how do you
know they have to come down more if you
won't even concede they're down 20 how
do you even know what they are
i know that they're way higher than they
were when biden got in there we got to
fix that problem okay so
it's it's not sounding like you're
willing to even in good faith concede
they're down 20 can you tell me why
um i can tell you that i care about hot
gas prices because it affects everybody
especially those who are poor in working
class in the middle class as well all
right so we're going to pause it there
um i'm up for going back for it uh it
would be great for if if we get some
some membership action we'll maybe debut
the entire thing after the trial today
otherwise sometime in the next week
that'll that'll get published it's
pretty wild stuff we get into keystone
xl
we get into uh oh my god it gets really
really bonkers and he did um
it was weird stuff it was really really
weird stuff okay couple other things to
look at um
white nationalist nick fuentes ended up
on russian tv check this out well i
think the uh rhetoric towards russia
since the beginning of this conflict
nothing more than russophobia
and they talk about russia
the regime and the people in a way which
is just plain prejudice and bigoted uh
they talk about russians as though
they're uncivilized treat them like
they're not human beings and it's a
little bit ironic because the
opposition to the special military
operation in ukraine is supposedly about
so-called human rights
about democracy
i can't even stomach it so nick fuentes
is now on uh he's on rt
here's a woman
uh who i guess was in the bathroom
during landing on a plane
and they kept asking her to come out and
then i guess she went completely bonkers
let's see a bunch of you sent this to me
well let's get them all rolling
we have friends yet
nothing magic
excuse me
i work off this thing
they haven't opened the
[Music]
uh
all right i'm not finding it that
interesting uh but it is it is weird
certainly
um next clip here's roger stone on
infowars and alex jones pops up with no
shirt for some reason in an audio tape
that he said the president should be
forced to resign
and then we need to get a commitment
from mike pence that he will not be
pardoned who's the best dressed right
here
anybody know why roger stone is red like
a tomato ladies and gentlemen alex jones
that is a freaking predator right there
yeah
so that's pretty strange
um a lot of a lot of just weird stuff
going on lately where it's like
it's unclear what's going on oh that's
spray tan on his face okay fair
uh thank you to captain smiles for
gifting two subscriptions on twitch also
thanks to christopher hatch for the
twitch prime that puts us at uh 4
not 4s just 4.
also big thank you to ames bookwalter
who is new member number five today
signing up on my website and a big thank
you to connor forbes connor forbes just
gifted a subscription on my website
which you can do
really easily by checking this box is
this a gift
super super easy
um and that
free membership goes to i hope i
pronounce this correctly
zainep bulgouk
i don't know doing the best i can with
all of the names very very much
appreciate that a couple voicemails for
everybody a lot of people weighing in on
the johnny depp trial let's see if i can
find
some of them
uh okay not this not this not this
not this
um
actually a lot of a lot of off the rails
stuff happening right now
um
let's see
hi david my name is luke i'm from
niagara on the lake ontario canada and
i've been enjoying your show for a
couple years now and i agree with 99
percent of your opinions including the
questionable medical advice offered by
dr menodos
but for the sake of consumer protection
in the right amounts
minerals such as iron zinc and copper
are ingestible and can be found on the
back of select multivitamin labels when
it comes to silver many people take too
much or being ripped off pain too much
for colloidal silver when there is
little to none in the water
at the right level silver is a mineral
supplement just like copper zinc and
iron but it remains a question as to the
effectiveness of drinking silver and
what results you can expect or help yeah
there's actually a lot of rcts uh about
silver
and i encourage you to uh to check those
out let's listen
well we've got a really annoying hum
there so i'm going to keep things muted
do both streams have the hum
wow that's horrible horrible horrible
audio
um that's that's really too bad thanks
to jen here for the twitch prime gift
over on twitch it's great to be on
twitch and so great to have all of you
here uh yeah drinking silver can turn
you blue which i guess some people maybe
like but
i don't in particular i'm not looking to
be turned blue
um so saying there are certainly
questions about drinking silver
is quite an understatement quite an
understatement i would say
so one thing that i feel like would
benefit um both
republicans and
democrats
is um
they're doing
more like socialism in france
and i noticed that some of the canadians
come down and they really like the
republicans man i don't know what she's
going on about
this is jonathan in los angeles trump
keeps on bringing up these cognitive
tests
i don't think the doctors would have
recommended the cognitive test if they
didn't see some kind of a
problem with this
cognitive cognitive right
uh yeah no that's that's a very very
good point i was actually looking for
some about the johnny depp trial
and i'm not really finding any hey dave
i think madison cawthorne whose name is
really david costthorne but he uses
madison because he wants to sound like a
founding father i think he brings these
guns with him to airports on purpose i
think so too okay let's listen
the jury is re-entering the humming is
so annoying i know guys trust me the
humming is on
it's on their end it's not on my end
everybody relax
thanks to sheryl nelson for signing up
on my website welcome cheryl your new
member number seven you want to continue
with this witness thing
yes thank you your honor we'll now play
volume two of mr carino's deposition
which is the questioning from council uh
for mr depp okay thank you
you're aware that this litigation
involves a dispute between uh johnny
depp and amber heard correct
correct
and you know both of those individuals
correct
correct
who did you meet first
amber
when did you meet her
i i don't know
exactly when
but
probably within
the first few years of being at ca
okay
so can we as an estimate stay
2005-2006 time frame
sure i don't actually know but sure
but it was pretty early on at your
career in caa
correct
and describe for me the events of your
meeting her
um she was represented theatrically at
the time
by
an agent named warren zavala
who
has since left caa
and he brought her down to my office
because he wanted me to
represent her with him
specifically in the commercial space
and what do you mean represent her in
the commercial space
um help identify
business opportunities for her with
brands
okay so not as an actor
correct
and did you take on that representation
i did
and at some point in time you did
consider her a friend in addition to
you two working together is that right
yes
and in that regard did
you uh you and her do anything social
yes
and can you describe for me generally
what types of activities you two would
do together as friends
we would uh
go to dinner go to events together
hang out at
each other's
residences
and at some point at some point in time
did you consider mr defend
yes
and
how did that relationship evolve and i'm
just talking about you and mr depp
becoming friends
i
spent
a fair amount of time with
both of them together
and at some point started to spend time
with him on my own as well
and at some point in time did mr depp
become a good a friend to you as miss
hurt
i'm sorry
let me re-ask that also
did you consider
at some point in time did you consider
mr depp a friend to the same degree you
consider it miss herder friend
yes
and at some point
let me ask you at some point in time did
you
represent
mr deb professionally yes and can you
explain to me how it how it came to you
representing mr debt professionally
johnny asked me to represent him
and when you began representing mr depp
did you continue representing ms hurd
yes
and do you recall who mr depp's agent
was
priority he was represented at another
town agency uta do you still work for mr
dev
i do not
you recall when you stopped working for
mr
within the past two years
and um
can you describe the circumstances of
you no longer working for mr depp
he
left
caa
to follow
an agent who
left caa
to become part of a founding group in a
new management company
and who is that person
jack wiggum
was mr wiggum ever affiliated with caa
yes
okay
and
say that when jack wiggum departed t.a.a
johnny went with him
yes
and
when mr depp left
left caa
did you remain
did you remain friends with him
no
okay
well i should probably first ask at some
point in time
um
did your friendship with mr defend
yes
and when was that
i would say
at the time he left
caa
and did him even have something to do
with uh the end of the friendship
i don't know are you still friends with
ms heard
no
and when did that friendship end
probably when
the
legal disputes started
and what legal dispute are you referring
to
this one
good
i'm not sure which one was first but one
of the disputes between johnny and amber
okay but
your friendship would
you're not referring to their divorce
correct
correct okay so you remain friends with
both of them through their divorce is
that accurate
yes
although you're no longer friends with
mr depp do you have any animosity
towards him
i do not
and same question with respect to miss
hurt although you're not friends with
her any longer do you have any animosity
towards her i do not
do you recall when it is the last time
you spoke with miss heard
i do not
would it have been around the same time
that um
your friendship ended with her
i would assume so
exhibit 16.
now uh mr cream
you'll see at the bottom here and
let me if you can see it if you see at
the bottom it has a bait stamp number
under the yellow tag
seven
cc0070
yes do you recognize this document
and take your time if you need to review
it
pretty explosive stuff
so
yes
okay and do you understand this to be a
true uh an authentic copy of
email exchange in which you were
involved
i believe so
okay
okay and it's you'll see it's dated
january 11 2018 and the subject is wme
do you know what what is your
understanding of what wme is
william morris endeavor
and what is that
it's another talent agency
okay
um
and you've you've read this email from
miss her to you correct
correct
so at this point in time would you
was she a close friend of yours
yes and ultimately did she leave caa
yes and it was at this time
yes
during the the entire time you
represented uh ms heard
did mr depp ever interfere
with your representation
of misheard
no
did he ever ask you to do anything
uh with respect to
um
her career
not that i can recall except 17
now mr crano this particular document
was not produced by you
you'll see that
at the bottom here
the bait stamp
indicates alh
that means it was produced by miss heard
and
this appears to be a text exchange
between you and her
it's about a page and a half if you
could take the time to read it and then
i will ask you questions about it
you'll see at the top
mr carino that it's dated
uh july 14 2016.
based on that date and based on reading
this
text exchange
at this point in time uh
were you close friends with both mr depp
and mrs heard
yes
and having read the text exchange
do you believe do you believe this to be
a
true and correct
uh representation of the exchange
yes and to be authentic in that regard
yes
you start the text exchange by
indicating jd just surfaced who is what
is the jd reference
johnny depp
and she says i saw laurel yesterday
uh who is laurel
laurel's a therapist
do you know her full name
laurel anderson did you independently
know laurel
yes
did you have anything to do with um
laurel
seeing either misheard or mr deb
yes
and can you explain that to me please
i introduced them all
and
was
what was the purpose of you introducing
her to them
they needed
help
and can you explain to me in more detail
what you mean by that
i think it was out of time where they
needed somebody to help mediate
the difficulties they were having
and what do you mean by difficulties
the strains on their relationship and
in that regard
um did you have conversations with miss
heard
about the state of her relationship with
mr def yes i'm trying to determine for
how long a period of time
uh did miss hurt have conversations with
you
about the state of her relationship with
mr dev
can you give me um
a time frame
i would say
she talked to me about the state of the
relationship
from the beginning until the end
the entire time you knew her i'm sorry
the entire time you considered her a
friend
yeah
okay
and how about mr dev um would you
how would you
did you have conversations with him
about the state of his relationship with
mr
yes
and were those ongoing during the entire
time you were friends with him
yes
say they both confided in you in you in
that regard
yes
so back to this text
exchange where my cursor is um
you i miss her and says to you yeah she
said that johnny and i need to talk
directly do you know who she is do you
know who ms heard's referring to there
laura that was your understanding after
reading this
yes
and then you asked her do you want to do
something tomorrow she says yeah
she says idp i do
uh
you say ha
okay
and then you say what is safe to do do
you want to come to my place for dinner
what did you mean by what is safe to do
it meant avoiding paparazzi okay
and then she says
it's so [ __ ] up i just want to tell
him that what they are telling him isn't
true what was your understanding of what
she meant by that sentence
i i don't recall
mr garino while she's doing that
at
um
at the outside of this deposition i
asked you
uh if you recall being deposed about a
year ago in this case
um and you said yes is that accurate
yes
okay what i'm going to show you now is
the transcript portion of the transcript
from that deposition and who is mr
bruckheimer
jerry bruckheimer is the producer of
the pirates franchise and who is mr
wiggum
jack wiggum
was an agent at ca
who worked with johnny
okay
and who is mr
lord
brian is one of the managing partners of
caa
and also worked
on johnny depp
and what was your understanding of
why
the pirate six
job was not offered to mr deb
leo you're asking my opinion
yes
because of the accusations that amber
had made
and what i'm about to show you mr
carrino is a
article in the washington post
authored by miss heard you're going to
notice that
the article will be presented sideways
so you'll have to tilt your head a bit
to review it
19 do you uh
first mr karina why don't you take
control and just
scroll through
the document it's just a couple pages
this is the former agent of both johnny
depp and amber of the
next page
yeah when there's a jump like that it's
just at the top of the next page
thanks to beef goggles for the twitch
prime subscription
you'd think they could just cut out him
reading it you know what i mean i mean
they cut out all sorts of other silences
it's kind of weird
please proceed governor
please
i don't know this guy seems to be
reading from right to left like it's
hebrew it's very suspicious
hmm
[Music]
i don't get why this isn't just cut out
of the video it doesn't make any sense
to me
unusual
hmm
[Music]
that i heard a frog
thanks to peter pajersky
for donating a subscription whoa where
did that come from that's the wrong
thing
uh that's number nine today
the lucky recipient is sophia vinicore
gets a free subscription thank you
[Music]
beautifully generous
i wonder what would happen if in a case
like this the witness literally read for
two hours and just didn't move and said
i'm sorry i'm reading
at some point what would the lawyers do
would they say it's been too long and
they go i don't know i haven't finished
reading it yet
thanks to trish breselyn for gifting a
subscription on my website that's number
10. okay
mr creator have you seen this document
before
yes
do you know who wrote this document
yes
who wrote this document amber
amber heard
yes
and do you see there on this first page
of the document
it actually indicates that it's written
by amber heard on december 18th 2018.
yes
and you understand that this document
was
authored by ms heard and published on
december 18 2018.
yes
and do you recall reading it at the time
it was published
no
mr uh crano i'm showing you an email
exchange in which you were involved
um it's just this one page i'll blow it
up so you can review it a lot of here's
a second to review it please
by the way yeah i forgot hearsay is our
coupon code i actually forgot about that
okay
and
let's start at the bottom of this well
you see at the top that the email
rayline is entitled johnny depp's jack
sparrow won't return the new pirates of
the caribbean movie
yes
and this email exchange was on december
20th 2018 correct
correct
and do you recall that the article you
just read published by ms heard was
published on december 18 2018 two days
before this
yes
now if you go to the bottom of this
email
do you see there is this link to an
article
yes
and it says uh
url defense
i'm sorry it says
movieweb.com
yes
mr carino what i put up next to the
email exchange that we've been
discussing
is an article
uh dated december 20th 2018 okay
so this article is dated december 20th
2018.
the email sent to you by
um
robin baum
is that same day december 20th 2018.
robin bong that's interesting yes who is
miss bomb or bomb johnny's publicist
and she's sending this article to you is
that right
yes
and then in response you say
um we were were we told this officially
from disney
and she responds
i'm sorry jack wiggum responds no is
that accurate
yeah
sure
so you testified uh just
a few minutes ago that it was your
opinion that
mr depp
lost
the pirate six movie because of miss
herd's allegations is that accurate
allegations of abuse correct
yes
and
is this a demonstration of
when
disney made that decision to not
uh hire mr depp for pirate sticks
yes
22.
did you ever see
mr depp
no physically abused miss hurt
no
did miss herd ever tell you that she had
been physically abused by mr death
no did you do mr depp ever tell you that
he had physically abused miss hurt
no
did you ever witness
any
injuries on misheard that would indicate
that she was physically abused
no
now again this is
a few months after the filing of the
divorce
and the tro
and miss heard states to you i'll call
you right back sorry
and you say okay
she says is it too late to call
and you say just finishing dinner we'll
call you as soon as we walk out within
20.
and she says please tell him
i love him
um
is that an accurate reading of the text
exchange so far
yes
do you know if at this time
uh based on your relationship with miss
hurt and mr depp
um
whether
miss heard wanted to reconcile with mr
deb
yes
did you understand that she did
yes
did
miss heard based on your personal
friendship with miss her close personal
friendship with miss heard
would you say
that she confided in you
and what about mr yes
mr craig at some point in time
uh after ms heard
filed his divorce papers in may of 2016.
um did she
make any requests of you to
intervene in
the relationship between her and mr bill
what do you mean by intervene
[Music]
assist in let's start with assistant
communications between the two
name objections
can you explain to me what transpired in
that regard
walk me through
at some point around that time
she wanted
me to arrange for them to get together
in person
and what did you do
after that was requested of you by mr
i
[Music]
talked to johnny about it what happened
after that
uh he was reluctant
at first and then agreed
and then what happened after that
i mean this long time ago but i remember
there was a fair amount of discussion
about
the tro
and how we would deal with that because
nobody wanted
johnny accused of violating the tro
as an outcome of
that meeting
and i don't remember exactly what we
did
but
amber at some point warranted that she
would never accuse him of violating the
tro to do the meeting
and
i set the meeting up
so just so i understand
you set the meeting up
at the request heard
objections
um
and as part of you setting up
she told you that
um
it didn't matter
what i'm trying to understand what what
was the issue with respect to the tro
my understanding of the
restraining order at least at the time
was that
he couldn't go within a certain
distance of
her
okay
and what was her suggestion
um
with respect to that issue
in connection with her wanting to meet
with him
she
promised me and told me to relay to him
that she would never accuse him
of violating
the restraining order
as a result of agreeing to meet her
and i believe but i
don't recall exactly there were
conversations with
both
sides legally i believe at the time
to make it transparent to everybody that
this was happening
okay
and then what happened next
um i arranged the meeting
johnny was
in
san francisco
on tour
and i arranged to borrow a friend's
house
and
amber and i flew to
san francisco and drove to the house
and
johnny showed up a few hours later
and did the two of them meet
yes
in the same room
they sat outside
okay
uh
how close to each other were they
inches away from each other
and how long uh
were they out there talking for how long
were they out there talking
several hours
did you
although you were out there did you
were you in a position where you could
see them through a window or otherwise
yes
at some point in time the conversation
ended correct
correct and what happened after that
i
received a call or a text from
steve whose house it was
and he
notified me that
he would be coming back
to the house
within the next hour or so and
i told
johnny and amber
and we decided to rent a hotel room in
san francisco
so that they could continue to talk wow
and did that in fact happen
objections
and at some point in time you left that
house correct to go to san francisco
yes
and was it the three of you
no
johnny had security with him
and
we talked about the fact that they
it wouldn't be
a good idea for them to be seen together
there
so
johnny left with his security in his car
and i believe amber and i took an uber
and what happened after that
we all met at the hotel
room
and you know what happened after that
um they started arguing
and do you recall any details of the
argument
no and for how long were you was this
argument had in a in a hotel room
yes
did you witness the entire discussion or
did you leave at some point
i left the next morning at
five
o'clock in the morning or six o'clock in
the morning and mr carino um i'm showing
you emails over produced by you first uh
the bottom of the first page it starts
at the bottom of the first page the
string above it was redacted and you'll
see that it starts on august 7th 2017 do
you see that
august 7th 2017. yes having read it uh
can you determine who you're speaking
with in this text exchange amber oh hang
on let me ask you this do you know
whether or not um
miss heard ever
had a relationship with mr elon musk
yes
she did
yes so again it's dated
august
of 2017
um
[Music]
and she says dealing with breakup
i hate when things go public
see i'm so sad
um
having reviewed the document again do
you have an understanding of what she's
referencing there
um i believe she's referring to breaking
up with elon
you say seems like a press release
you weren't in love with him and you
told me a thousand times you were just
filling space what are you saying there
i'm saying
why would you be sad if you weren't in
love with them to begin with
and by him you're referring to who
and at this point i think musk is
expected to testify in this case is that
is that correct
uh looks looks like that's the case at
that time yes
and was did she still at this point in
time did she confide in you about her
relationship
yes
okay
and you respond
i'm sorry she responds
i know but i wanted time to grieve and
recover
in my own time
is she still referring to mr must bear
you know
your understanding i don't know whether
she's referring to johnny or to elon in
that line
okay
in this point of time do you know uh
what her feelings were what was your
understand at this point in time what
was your understanding based on
your experience with her what was your
understanding um
[Music]
of her relationship with mr deb
i
i don't believe there was a relationship
at that point
and
you say and you got that no she says
i hate that
yet again a man lets me fall on the
spikes by myself
you ask how so
she says
oops
meaning
they are mad at me for leaving them and
put things like this out there
you say
sorry
she says like that
you say
you could avoid all this if you stop
dating uber famous people
you can be with a big man who isn't
famous
what were you um relating to her there
i believe what i was saying was
if you don't like being in the press
about your personal life then
don't date people that are famous sure
um you indicated that she moved on
immediately uh after jd
uh after i'm sorry after johnny depp to
date elon musk is that accurate
yes okay sure
do you have an understanding one way or
another whether miss heard and mr musk
were in fact dating at the time of the
san francisco reconciliation that she
asked you to set up i i don't know
whether they were dating
but they
had definitely spent time together
reportedly when elon testifies they're
going to ask him if he plans to go to
nars the united states will be the first
nation to land an astronaut on nars fact
dating
i don't know
exactly how long but not long after
do you know who she's
what was your understanding of who she
was referring to when she was said here
i love him
johnny
based on this exchange did you have an
understanding at this time
whether miss
heard wanted to reconcile with mr duff
i believe she did
and at this point in time she was still
a close personal friend of yours correct
yes
and at this point in time was she
did she consider you a confidant in your
your understanding
i i think
yeah
okay just to uh
authenticate this document again mr
carrino do you see that
it's referenced at the bottom bait stamp
cc indicating that you produced this
document yes
and um
if having read this do you do you
perceive this as a transcript copy of
the text exchange between you and mr
miss heard
yes
okay
and i will um
can you be at the very top here it's
dated august 16 2017.
and miss heard states to you
i written so many notes
can you give him one
i don't know how or where to start
there's no way to begin and
all i have to say but i have so many
finally i am single clear in my heart
and mind i just want him to know i loved
loved him and that i am sorry
do you have an understanding of who ms
hurt is referring to here yes
[Music]
and who is miss her referring to in this
text johnny
and what is she um
asking you to do here
she was asking me to
deliver
a letter
that she was writing to him
and
did she also want you to explain and it
says and that i am sorry
uh what was your understanding of what
she was asking you to do there if
anything
i believe that was all in reference to
getting him
a handwritten letter that she was
writing or trying to write was it your
understanding at the time of this text
exchange august 24 2017 that miss amber
was attempting to reconcile with mr deb
i believe so
okay
and i know maybe this may sound
repetitive but
on august 20 at the time of this text on
august 24 2017
um you and her were still close personal
friends correct
i believe so
there's not much here at all um
mr cranial but i do want to confirm that
this was a document produced by you
correct based on the bait stamp on the
bottom
yes
and
do you see it's dated september 27 2017
september 23rd
oh you're right my apologies it's dated
september 23rd 2017. and it's a text to
you that says god i miss him
do you have an understanding of uh
what
not
who misheard is referring to there yes
and who's that
johnny
and do you see um at the bottom
the date of the text is june 9th
2018. yes
okay
and
uh it says i text him happy birthday
do you know who sent that and who the
him is i assume this is from amber and
she's talking about johnny you've had a
chance to review the whole document um
what is
what is it what does this appear to be
uh it appears to be the
around the time that we
set up the meeting
in um
and who are these communications between
me and johnny
okay
um
and this first uh bubble
um can you tell if that if the blue is
you or mr deb
ah i think the blue is is me
sure earlier in your deposition uh at
the very outset i was asking you about
your representation of individuals
at caa you indicated that you represent
individuals that are both actors and
musicians
would you consider mr depp in that pool
yes
and you represented your ca
representative both in connection with
his acting endeavors
and
his involvement with uh the vampires
yes
and
was mr deb's participation in
hollywood vampires lucrative
no
do you know whether or not it was
something mr jeff mr dev enjoyed
yes
plaintiff calls laura wasser by
deposition your honor w
a
s
s
e r thank you
will you please state your name and
address for the record
laura allison wasser
wasser cooperman and mandels suite 800
2049 century park east los angeles
california at nine zero
thank you what is your occupation
i'm an attorney at law
and how long have you been an attorney
26 years
you represented mr death in the divorce
against amber heard is that correct
yes
and you are here under subpoena
yes
your practice has primarily been focused
on domestic relations in california is
that
correct yes
are you a member of any bar other than
california
no
during the period 2012 to 2016
was california a no-fault state with
respect to divorce the answer is that
california was a no-fault state during
that period
during the period 2012 to 2016 was
california a community property state
with respect to the division of assets
in the divorce
yes
and what does that mean to you
california as a community property state
and what that means to me is that assets
which were earned or created during the
course of the marriage
absent some other
theory of law applied be divided
equally
and what do you mean by absolutely some
theory or law applied
i'm sorry elaine what was the question
oh a theory of a lot when i say a theory
of lie mean if there's a premarital
agreement if there's some other
it's not completely
uh blanket community property there may
be
things that were earned from a separate
property source that would not be
considered
community property so i was just trying
to
provide
for the record
some exceptions to what would be
considered community property and
therefore divided equally
now if someone alleges domestic violence
or abuse against their spouse would that
change the amount they would otherwise
be entitled to under community property
laws
no
in obtaining
a temporary restraining order
what is your understanding of the
process
the moving party
files
generally with
24 hours notice
to the
person who is being accused of domestic
violence
a declaration and forms
with the court
and
requests a temporary
domestic violence restraining order
that will generally last no longer than
a 21 day period
when the defendant is able to make his
or her
arguments as to why such a restraining
order would be inappropriate
and
the temporary restraining order can it
be continued
yes
when did you first begin representing mr
death relating to his divorce within
bihar
uh
i believe it was in
december of 2015.
i'm going to ask you to pull up
document one washer document one and
let's go ahead and label that as washer
exhibit number one
ms watson so i'm going to ask you to
take a look at what has been marked as
washer deposition exhibit number one
it is a letter dated may 24 2016.
it's addressed to jacob bloom
[Music]
uh and it says re in remarriage of death
do you see that yes
okay and it's from
samantha spector
who indicates she's representing amber
heard
as of the time of this letter
had you made known to
amber heard or miss specter
or anyone else related to them that you
represented mr depp
i don't believe so
did you
receive a copy of this letter from
someone
i believe so i think i've seen it before
so yes
did you receive this letter
on or around may 24 2016.
okay next page please
hang on
yes it was around that time
around may 24 2016.
yes
did you have any communications with
samantha specter
in connection with this letter
yes
and when you say within days
could it have been the same day may 24th
the next day 25th
possibly i'm going to direct your
attention to the next paragraph it says
to this end please have johnny promptly
signed and returned by friday may 27
2016
the enclosed notice of acknowledgement
received form confirming service of the
summons petition law case cover sheet
and blank response
did you do that
this letter was not directed to me
elaine
no i i understand it but it was given to
you correct
i believe so
and you were representing mr deb correct
yes
and
mr bloom did not represent mr depp in
connection with the
divorce correct
correct
so
once
mr bloom gave this to you
then
did you represent mr depp going forward
in communication to a cement perspective
once we received this letter
our firm took over with representation
of mr depp in the dissolution action
i cannot recall whether or not
the
request made was done by
friday may 27th but i believe that it
was
probably not notice an acknowledgment of
receipt somewhere with a date on it
now the next section i think is
something that you referred to earlier
said in addition we are requesting on
amber's behalf the following
and it talks it says appropriate
condensate like support
uh did you have an understanding of what
that amount might be at the time that
you saw this letter
i did not have an understanding of what
appropriate pendente elite support would
be at that time did you ask for mount
the spectre
i don't recall
i don't recall our specific
communications regarding her requests
do you recall
making any kind of counter to any of
these items
all i recall is that
without any notice to us at 8 30 in the
morning on the 27th
samantha spector and her client went
into court and obtained a no notice
ex parte
restraining order
had you had any communications
with samantha specter prior
to her going into court
on that friday may 27th
yes
how many communications had you had with
ms spector prior
following getting this letter and prior
to her going into court at 8 30 on may
27 2016.
i do not recall
do you have a recollection of whether
any of the communications that you had
with ms spector between the receipt of
this letter
that's dated may 24
2016 and going and miss specter going
into court
on
friday may 27 2016
related in any way
to requests on your behalf on behalf of
your client that you make
now
you recall having communications with
samantha specter
between may 24 and may 27
you can't recall how many and you can't
recall the specifics of those
communications is that accurate
it's not accurate
and
in what way please tell me
i recall that we had communications
between the 24th and probably the 26th i
doubt we spoke on the movies this is
pretty devastating testimony i do not
know the content of those communications
and i do not know how many
communications were had
now on the
next paragraph it has a proposal for
private
retired judicial officers
ultimately did you and ms spector talk
about using private retired judicial
officers whether it was the list she
provided or any others
i believe so yes
and what do you recall
my recollection is that is in almost all
of our cases certainly those with high
profile
clients
we would have liked to take it out of
the system
miss spectre was not willing to do that
with this case
what do you recall this specter saying
to indicate that she did not want to
take it out of the contract
i don't recall her saying anything
now
after your understanding was that a
kletz dv tro was in fact obtained on
friday may 27 2016 by ms heard against
mr jeff correct
that is my understanding
after that
did there come a time
that you or anyone on
at your law firm
communicated with the eastern columbia
building concierge staff or management
were those the downtown lofts
the the penthouse marks yes
and if it's easier for you everyone's
been referring to the eastern columbia
building as ecb
would that be helpful at all
sure or we can if you prefer to call
them the penthouse loft building that's
fine too
now that we've identified them i
understand what you're talking about we
can call them whatever you'd like
did someone from my firm speak with
somebody uh at the
at those
buildings yes
and
from your firm spoke with someone at the
buildings
and when it seems like lawyers don't
really love having to be deposed in
situations like this believe either i
did or my partner samantha klein or an
associate who is also working on the
case
lisa sutton
from our firm
we also had co-counsel on the case they
may have been involved
as to when i have to imagine it was
sometime
in
june or july
of
2016.
now you you indicated either you or
samantha klein of lisa sutton and you
also had co-counsel do you have a
specific recollection of speaking with
anyone at the ecb
building
i
don't what were samantha klein's
communications with the ecb building
i don't know
what were samantha klein's communication
with easy with the ecb building
okay and her answer was i don't know
what were lisa's sentence communications
with the ecb building
i don't know
what were
your co-consuls communications with the
ecb building when i say ecb building i'm
not talking about the structure i'm
talking about the individuals who worked
there
and just so we're clear here you don't
recall any communications with the ecb
building staff as well correct
you asked me if i had a specific
recollection i do not
do you have a general regiment
i believe that at some point we
subpoenaed the building's records of
the uh
video
they actually subpoenaed all the
machines in the building we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines
and that the communications would have
to do with those subpoenas
are you able
to testify to any
conversation
you
or anyone at your firm or your co-consul
had with the ecb building staff
i spoke to the routers that there were
conversations and communications
regarding
the production of
the subpoenaed documents
review of the subpoena documents
um
their compliance with i believe it was
miss specter's
subpoena
that was sent
yeah this is the butler's butler's
assistance lawyer
but i don't have a specific recollection
of any communications
[Music]
are you able to speak to whether there
were any conversations
between you
anyone at your law firm or your
co-consul and ecb building personnel
prior to your issuing
the subpoena
also i don't believe that the subpoena
was issued by our firm
so you don't have a recollection
of a subpoena being issued
on mr depp's behalf
for the
ecb building
surveillance tapes
i don't know i know there was one issued
i believe it was issued by miss specter
wow
let's talk about the videos that you
just referred to from the ecb building
staff
how did you and your firm or your
co-counsel
receive these videos
[Music]
i don't recall i would imagine a like a
e file or something like that
now is it your recollection
that there was just one e file that
contained all of the surveillance tapes
i don't have a recollection as to
whether it was one or seven or what i
just don't know
when you were talking about receiving
the video surveillance footage
on whatever whether it was one file or
seven files whether it was e-file or
whatever did you have any understanding
that you were not provided the full
amount that was requested whatever the
amount was
no
so you thought you
received whatever you were supposed to
receive is that fair
yes
what did you do
with the actual
surveillance video footage that you
received
i believe we kept it on the computer at
least for the next couple of months in
preparation for trial
i don't know where it is now
that's my next question
is there a time
that you
no longer possess the video surveillance
footage that was sent to you
by the ecb building
i don't know
ms west i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as watson
deposition exhibit number two and it's a
multi-page document
and so i'm going to
scroll down a little bit but you can let
me know if i'm going too fast here um
it's dated june 3rd
and it's to samantha klein she's with
your she was working with you on the
depth case correct
correct
okay and it's from samantha specter
which you can see there and they'll show
you the signature later
and it's litigation called preservation
of information
and it was
not limited to electronically stored
information you see that yes
do you recall receiving this letter and
if you want me to scroll down let you
leave each page i'm happy to do that
first i'm familiar with this letter i
recall receiving it
and
did you receive this letter
before
you received the
surveillance
footage from the ecb building
um
i am not sure
well i think you had indicated that you
thought that it was in june or july that
you received the surveillance footage is
that still your best recollection
i'm
looking at the date and knowing the
chronology of the case it is
my best estimate that we received this
letter prior to the time that we
received
the video footage
ms wasser
what steps did you and your firm and
co-consul take
to preserve the surveillance
video footage of ecb
from the time you received it going
forward
i think
the absence of us doing anything to
destroy the video footage would be the
most i could testify regarding in terms
of steps that we took to preserve
the video footage
are you aware
of any
destruction of the video footage the
surveillance video footage from ecb
up to the present
no i we probably still have it
have have you looked for it
no
have you been asked to look for it
no
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
uh what is melbourne largest watson
deposition exhibit number three
and it's dated june 6 2013.
addressed to you
and it's from charles carter did you
have an understanding that mr carter
also represented amber heard
i did when i received this letter on
june 6.
and did you have an understanding that
mr carter was also asking you to
preserve any evidence
yes
ms wasser i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as vastly
deposition exhibit number four it's
dated june 6th as well and it's the
charles carter
from your phone
and you are acknowledging we see that
the preservation demand [ __ ]
was hurt as well as his
uh and you indicated
we are fully aware of our obligations
with respect to the preservation of
evidence
please rest assured that we intend to
comply with the preservation demand and
expect that this person will do so as
well
do you recall saying that in this letter
yes
and was this letter in fact from you to
mr harden
it was
watch i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as loss of
deposition exhibit number five it's a
letter dated june 21 2016
to samantha specter charles carter and
leonard levine i think it's pronounced
remarriage of death
and it's from
[Music]
samantha klein do you see that
and you are copied on it do you see that
i do okay and miss klein worked with
your law firm
yes
and represented mr deputy as well
is that correct yes okay uh i'm going to
go back up to the beginning to call your
attention to a particular section
it says this letter shall confirm the
agreements we reached yesterday with
respect to the pending domestic violence
proceedings see that
and then we're going to go down to the
media
press and it says neither party nor his
or her respective counsel
representatives or agents so make any
comments in the media or class
pertaining to this dissolution action
the civil action depending against drugs
for health and are any pending or future
litigation between our and or involving
the parties to see that
yes all right does that
uh accurately reflect the agreement that
was made between
the parties with respect to ingrid and
mr depp in communications with the press
yes
do you know liz walton's
who
liz walters
yes
and who is she
she is a
reporter or
i believe she works for her brother's
online media outlet called the blast
did you have any communications with liz
walters during the depth her divorce i
don't recall
[Music]
did you have any communication to your
tmz relating to the debt for divorce
i don't recall
hmm
now
the
what do you recall what the date was for
the permanent
uh tro temporary restraining
do you recall the date you said that
early on 21 days after the temporary
restraining order is typically the date
that's set for the hearing for the
defendant if they want to come in and
oppose it or if the
petitioner wants to extend it you recall
what the first date was
i don't but i would imagine it was
probably at some point in early june
all right
and then do you recall that date being
continued
i do
how many times
at least twice
possibly three times i think that the
final
date was at some point in august and we
settled
right before then
all right can
alan can we bring up
number
document number seven
pretty weaponized stuff
i believe i will be covering the trump
rally friday about 90 percent
thank you um mr i'm going to ask you to
take a look at what has been marked as
wasser exhibit number seven
it is dated august 5 2016.
it is to you
from
samantha specter do you see that
yes do you recall did you receive this
stuck
but doesn't it say at the top that it's
protected under 11 52.
it sure does all i'm asking you is
whether you received it i'm not not
asking you about the substance
i don't remember
do you have any reason to believe you
did not receive it
i don't
laster i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what the remarkable roster
deposition exhibit number oh my god look
at this
and it starts out
with a name now from samantha specter to
amber on august 6 2016.
um
do you recall
what was going on
am i off sugar yeah that's kind of a
random question but like no i mean i'm
not i'm not off sugar if i get if i
order tiramisu
i know there's sugar in it but what i do
is
when an item doesn't need sugar i avoid
the sugar so like if you go to the
grocery store and you want to get
granola for example all of these
granolas they add massive dumps of sugar
i don't need that so like i found a
granola i believe it's cascadian farm
not a sponsor that has no added sugar so
i'm not off sugar but i'm not adding
sugar where you don't need it i don't
add sugar to coffee for example thank
you
organizing if you will or assisting mr
dependent is hard
with
their own
meeting to try to resolve
their case up in san francisco
possibly that sounds vaguely familiar
are you on the telephone
at any point while amber hurd and john
depp were meeting
to discuss
attempted resolution
resolution of the issues during the
summer of 2016.
what was your question was i on the
telephone
yes
were you on the telephone
where mr depp and ms heard
were in the hotel room
and were talking
no
were you ever on the telephone
when ms hurd and mr depp were together
talking during the summer of 2016. no
matter where they were
on the telephone yes
no
while he was with ms heard
and miss heard was on speaker that and
you were on speakerphone with the two of
them
no you recognize the name
do you recognize the name on what joe
sweeney
i do
and who was he
joe sweeney is a forensic accountant uh
who specializes in family law forensic
accounting and he was ms heard's
forensic accountant in the disso matter
wow
and was edward white
acting as the forensic accountant for mr
death
no
did mr white provide the documentation
that was then submitted to samantha
specter as counsel for ms heard
i believe
came from mr white's office also
probably of note is the fact that mr
depp changed business management
shortly before or during the course of
the case so it is possible that some of
the documents came from predecessor
business manager
i'm going to show you what
has been marked as lasso deposition
exhibit number 10
and i'm not going to ask you
any specific questions so i don't need
you to have to review it in detail
unless you'd like to you're certainly
welcome to spend as much time as you'd
like on it but i'm just going to go down
to the end of it
and i'm going to
ask if this
is the deal point memorandum that you
referred to that was finalized on august
15 2016.
since the party's signatures appear at
the bottom as well as miss specters and
mine i believe that this is the deal
point memorandum that to which i was
referring okay
is there any reason to believe
that it is not the the final deal point
memorandum
no
ms wasser i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as washer
deposition exhibit number 11
and it's a series of
documents
an fl 150 for example
and then
that's page 404 and then it goes into
the next
part one of one
oh for people asking if uh i've gotten
rid of the nuisance cat in my garden
beds i believe i have i basically got
some
chicken wire
and created a sort of cage around much
of it and then i also got an ultrasonic
cat repeller it makes an insane
high-pitched noise which i find insane
it has a motion sensor
and it seems to be keeping everything
away squirrels everything
do you recognize this
document yes
could you tell me what it is please
it looks to be
one of the parties i guess mr depp's and
cyanide yeah california preliminary or
perhaps final declaration of disclosure
there's financial disclosure forms
there's last one i'm going to ask you
if you can
take a look at what has been marked as
glasser exhibit number 12.
it is audible to humans but it only goes
off when there's something right in
front of it
many pages
i think it's 50 total
do you recognize this document
yes
can you tell me what it is
it's the party's
avoided judgment for dissolution of
marriage
is there a specific amount
that was paid to amber heard as part of
this divorce
settlement judgment
for objection
foreign violence
including any claims of assault battery
intentional or negligent infliction of
emotional distress viable slander and
defamation
i don't believe that we segregated out
what the total amount was being paid for
did you make any effort to seal sbal
the records
in this case and i'm referring to the
case in front of us the uh
the the uh
marriage or partnership of amber laura
depp and john christopher depth ii
filed in superior part of california
county of las vegas
[Music]
when you say sealed do you mean by the
court to ask the court to seal the file
yes
i don't believe so
and why not
[Music]
we don't do that
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
what has been marked as
people in chat i didn't really get
cyanide for the cat i just got the
chicken wire and the ultrasonic
repellent i don't even think it's legal
it's a joke guys everybody relax this
deposition did you receive that
man
do you want you want me to scroll
through it would you like to
no i i i believe that we received it all
right and and you are testifying
pursuing for this subpoena correct
i am
i'm going to ask you to look at what has
been marked as deposition exhibit number
14.
um and this is
for the corporate designee of washer
cooperman and
mendoz you see that i did
for
today's deposition
is it your understanding that the tape
is going to end
on behalf of wasser cooperman and
mendel's
speaking today
yes
and there it is
thank you
all right ladies and gentlemen i think
uh
giving the hour that'll be all the
testimony that you hear today okay so
we'll go ahead and recess for the day
make sure you don't do any outside
research and don't talk to anybody and
we'll see you tomorrow okay
thank you
what a nightmare
the case has really become a slog
whatever you do make sure you go to the
bathroom somewhere other than the
courtroom
okay
and tomorrow then we'll be starting with
that other deposition
that's correct and how long is that or
approximately
two and a half hours i'll take care of
the morning probably for the most part
and then you have remote witnesses after
that is that correct
okay so you can get me the contact
information for those so we can get that
taken care of all right just remember we
do plan accordingly because i do need to
take lunch between 1 30 and 2 30 because
there's a graduation i have to speak at
so we're going to take care of that okay
all right thank you have a good evening
wow what a what a sl
what a slog this has become ladies and
gentlemen thank you so much for joining
me uh we will be live tomorrow for some
elements of it
and uh we'll be live on friday evening
most likely for the trump rally
this is an al pacino is it no it's not
uh so we're gonna watch all of it all
right everybody we'll see you very soon
thank you for joining me
have your uh pets spayed and neutered
thank you